so aside from the game and half time we
were so excited to see
what they came up with for commercials
yesterday yeah so alex we're going to
run through some of
our favorites here yeah i'll start with
uh will ferrell remember that thing he
did for
uh the electric car for gm check it
[Music]
up you fish out oh
this place is adorable damn it
where are you guys we're in finland
where are you
i'm in norway norway you're in sweden
damn it
yeah they had a whole bunch of buildup
leading to that commercial you know they
were like teasing it saying
why does will ferrell hate norway
apparently he hates the entire globe
because he punched the globe
yeah man he got a problem
it might not be easy but it'll be
amazing
i can't wait to meet her i thought this
was a super inspiring commercial this
was toyota as a sponsor for team usa
the paralympic swimmer jessica long and
the story of her adoption from siberia
as a baby
informing her parents that her legs
would have to be amputated
and they said we can't wait we'll take
her and we'll
it'll be an amazing life and it sure has
been for her
i love that yeah that was a great one
look guys i don't even have a stand in
of course you do hold on is that drake
that's right
drake from state farm like a good
neighbor
like a good neighbor stand-ins don't
have lines
oh okay like a good neighbor state farm
is there
can y'all guess who picked this one yeah
this of course is my pick
uh yeah i love this commercial because
of drake
uh we were talking about who the weeknd
may have brought in
for his special you know a special guest
for halftime
our guest maybe some of our hope was
that'll be drake that didn't happen
obviously but
we did get him it could have been drake
in one of those masks we don't know you
know that's true
you got him in the commercial sure but
yeah that was my pick
you even had him in the shower it wasn't
me
i even got you on camera wasn't me
oh okay
well that's the first time that's ever
worked hey man shaggy
so this is my favorite commercial the
cheetos mainly because i actually
like cheetos and i like ashton kutcher
and mila kunis they're pretty cool
together so yeah that was my favorite i
just kind of liked it it was easy breezy
kind of a fun little uh
yeah commercial to think a whole lot
about it it was really cute
that was good i just love them all
together yeah they're super cute
yeah those are our favorite commercials
there's a lot to choose from this year i
feel like
everyone kind of had lower expectations
because of the situation with
the pandemic and the production and
everything but i thought overall i'd
like the doordash commercial too with
the sesame street characters